[Music]
sufficient
after the earthquake which you care
today we received hundreds of casualties
the situation is too bad because a lot
of people are still under the debris of
the buildings really we need Argent well
for the areas special are talking about
medical help
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
still now many families now are under
the rubble our our Fab our teams trying
to save them trying to save their people
to save the older people from under
double with all cavities but it's it's
it's very difficult task for us we need
help we need the International Community
to do something to help us to support us
North Louisiana now it's a disaster area
we need help from everyone